now McCarthy's also threatened to Bar
Eric swalwell who sits on the house
Intel committee despite having a past
relationship with a suspected Chinese
spy all three members responded with
outrage towards McCarthy and Republicans
but as Newt Gingrich rightly reminded
everyone it was Nancy Pelosi that set
the precedent after removing Paul Gozer
and Marjorie Taylor Greene from their
committee assignments Newt Gingrich
former Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor joins us with more I mean I
think that's the funny part of it
they're all outraged about it but they
set the standard now the rules apply to
them and now they don't like it
well look but that's typical of the
Democrats they think it's so if they
cheat it's okay and if you're honest you
must be cheating uh so I think Pelosi at
the time I said this is a terrible
precedent uh this sets a stage for the
majority party to decide who gets to
serve on every committee uh and she she
went ahead and did it all these folks
supported her in doing it and now it's
come back around to bite them and
frankly the three people that speaker
designate
McCarthy has picked are perfect examples
one at Omar is an openly
anti-semitic anti-israeli bigot she
certainly should not be in the Foreign
Relations Committee uh swalwell has
various relations with Chinese who are
supposed to be spies he certainly should
not be on the intelligence committee and
frankly if I could have done it I would
have had Chef on no committee at all
Schiff is a liar he was there as the
chairman of the intelligence committee
he used that post which presumably gave
him unique knowledge and he just
routinely lied and every lie was a smear
of the president United States so I have
no sympathy for any of the three of them
and I'm very proud that speaker
designate McCarthy has in fact followed
through on his commitment and is going
to take them off their committees what
advice do you have now that the
Republicans have a pretty similar
majority they'll have as the last
Congress where the Democrats had control
obviously in the Judiciary Jim Jordan
will investigate whether the FBI has
been politicized and the doj weaponized
then Congressman Comer is looking into
Hunter and Joe Biden he said this is an
investigation into the president of the
United States I've often pointed out
that most people are missing the obvious
and that was there was a reason that Joe
withheld a billion dollars from Ukraine
there's a reason that Hunter complains
bitterly about all the money he has to
pay his dad and apparently now according
to Congressman Comer uh they're even
banking records that will corroborate
Joe Biden financially benefited from his
zero experience son making you know all
these deals with up to 50 countries uh
making millions and with no experience
with any of them and some of our most
hostile you know regimes out there China
Russia Etc
well look I mean first of all I think
the American people have the right to
know about a lot of things frankly I'd
like to know how much money the
University of Pennsylvania got from the
Chinese Communist how much of that went
to Joe Biden and what was in effect a
White House staff waiting in the wings
uh all that's been kept secret the
University of Pennsylvania will not
admit how many millions of dollars it
took so there's a lot there that ought
to be looked at my advice though would
be that the American people would like
this Congress to be 10 percent
investigations and 90 percent Solutions
we have a lot of real problems and we
need real action on a wide range of
things I like the fact that the speaker
designate McCarthy's already said the
very first vote is going to wipe out the
87 000 Internal Revenue Service agents
that's a policy decision not just an
investigation so my advice would be
twofold one try to discipline yourself
so it's 90 percent good Solutions 10
percent invest investigations that's
plenty of time to get a lot done and
second House Republicans have to learn
to be a team they can have all the
fights in the conference they want but
this recent suggestion that some of them
might not vote for McCarthy on January
3rd is so suicidal and so stupid that
you really have to wonder where they're
at I mean do they really want to see the
moderate Republicans join the Democrats
in getting some kind of Coalition
speaker I mean what's their end game
other than throwing a temper tantrum
they can have all the fights they want
inside the conference they have to work
together when they're on the floor you
know you said about this election year
that you know for you to fully
understand it you're going to have to
throw away every model that you knew in
past elections so I've been I've been
thinking a lot about what you said and I
think voting now in the last two
elections the way we vote more mail-in
voting absentee voting or you know early
voting all this stuff voting by mail
that is change pretty drastically now in
the country I'm not sure if Republicans
have bought into it
um then I I can't reconcile the
Republicans winning the the popular vote
uh by such a large margin and not
winning by a bigger margin uh then we
have this thing that I've been telling
you about accelerated migration they're
leaving blue states to avoid shutdowns
lockdowns they want their kids to have
in-person learning and they want lower
taxes so they move to Red states to get
redder but you know swing States like
Michigan and Wisconsin and Pennsylvania
going to get harder you know abortion
played a bigger part in this election
than I think anybody ever thought it
would and young people I think wanted
their their student loan forgiveness
they seem to show up in bigger numbers
what have you gleaned from the
information so far
well look I think a couple things first
of all uh the Republican model for
campaigning the Republican Consultants
are just wrong they're obsolete
Democrats focus on elections Republicans
focus on campaigns so Democrats begin uh
Gathering up votes very very early they
work at it very methodically some of the
Republicans and this and frankly uh the
truth is that Senator McConnell was a
major problem here because his Super PAC
which is a huge source of money refused
to spend money early well if you're
going to have early voting and you're
going to have coming out of a primary
the Democrats spends two or three months
defining the Republican and then the
people start to vote and by the time
McConnell starts to spend his money half
the votes already in uh you're you just
have an obsolete model so Republicans
have got to look at reality
early voting is real in some states
ballast uh boxes are real in some states
you're going to have to go out and
figure out how to get people to vote
very early and to stick to it and I
think that you also have to understand
we don't have an election day we now
have an election six weeks and
Republicans aren't ready for that I'll
tell you the last thing it's sad that
any voting takes place before debates
take place and Democrats have learned
from Joe Biden the hiding in your
basement bunker strategy with a
complicit liberal media seems to work
too and we better pay attention to that
former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else